the representation review is a review of
how people are represented within their
council it also reviews what
what the areas are that are represented
whether or not we want community boards
how many counselors we'd like to have on
our council
and what type of systems we want for
voting so it's legislatively required we
do it every six years it's always done
the year before an election
what we do is
you you count us to put a report
together and you have to find a way to
connect with your community and find out
what it is that they want
so what we've done in invercargill in
the past and this year is we've put
together an independent panel
and the independent panel is made out of
citizens throughout invercargill and
bluff
and they are a very diverse group so we
have business people we have someone
that works with the prison system
we've got an ex-counselor and they're
ranging in age from 80 to early 30s
we've tried to get a really diverse mix
of people that connect with different
people in invercargill to get the
message out well my role on the
independent panel obviously is to meet
with people and hear their views
and
the
consultation caravan is obviously
going to be the most visible way
in which
we'll be doing that
but also we'll be taking the opportunity
to
present to other community groups
whoever wants us to come and talk to
them or groups that we're involved in
that we can
uh chat to
um
as a group
and obviously
anyone that wants to
talk to us individually is more than
welcome to approach us and share the
views
with that information we then will build
a report that will go to council
once that report goes to council and
they accept it or make modifications
based on what they've heard it will go
out for public consultation
so the public consultations will run
from the 6th of august and they'll run
for 1 month or 30 days
that's where the public gets an idea of
where they get the option to say yeah we
completely agree with that or no we
don't we actually
think that we want less counselors
but what we're hoping is through our
feedback form that's in the back of our
pamphlets available
that people will be able to tell us in
advance
what their options are that they prefer
when you're voting you have three
different options of how you vote for
your council you have at large at large
means that you get to pick from your 12
counselors from anywhere within
invercargill and bluff
and the advantage to that is that you're
able to decide maybe a counselor on the
other side of town you think has
is a better representation of who you
are and what you want for your city
a disadvantage is you may not get people
in your community or in your direct area
that actually represent your needs or
maybe you don't feel they have an
understanding of what your community
needs directly
the next form of voting you can do is
called at large and award system so it's
a mix
the mix system allows for
having one demographic area where it's
at large and then you have a smaller
area
maybe like if bluff wanted to be part of
a ward system and they decided that that
they wanted only people elected from
their area
now the disadvantage to that is that
maybe you have to tie different areas in
because under the system you have to
have a certain amount of people
to vote
so bluff's population is quite small so
in order to say add bluff in is a part
of a mixed ward system
you would have to also tie in maybe the
end of invic article to get people
enough people to make that vote happen
so it can be a bit tumultuous as far as
whether or not you actually feel you're
being fairly represented
the other option is to do an all at ward
system an outward system means that the
city is divided into areas
those areas have to compile of enough
people so that
you've got enough representation so you
have to have a minimum number of people
that the counselor is going to
represent
um
the disadvantage is you only get to pick
people who live directly in that
demographic area so
if they're not in that geographical area
you won't be able to vote for them even
if you really like them and a
disadvantage can be
that you don't like the candidates you
have to choose from and you have no
choice but to vote for them and
sometimes in those situations you find
that candidates actually aren't getting
very many votes because maybe there just
isn't anybody that they don't have the
support to back them up
yeah some of the feedback we've gotten
is that maybe glengarry need a rate
payers group or some kind of a community
board other people have suggested south
city might need their own community
group
because they are largely doing projects
now through south alive and other
programs
kennington is another area that is being
considered for the possibility of having
community group because of their
geographical location they're a little
bit out of the city and their needs tend
to be a bit different as far as what
they need for example they don't
currently get garbage and recycling
it's things like that where you need to
really assess whether or not the
community has needs glengarry is quite
active but maybe they need more of a
voice at the council
and community boards or rate payers
groups allow them to do that
living in bluff and having worked with
both the previous community board and
and the current one
would certainly say that a good
community board
is an asset to a community of interest
bluffs
a small community geographically
separated from the rest of invercargill
and has particular concerns
and issues that are unique to bluff and
there may well be other communities
that are part of the city of
invercargill
such as kennington
um
that may feel the same way so so
definitely
i would think that
communities who feel they're not being
represented adequately through the
council
as it currently stands
may wish to to have a community board or
a rate payers group and may get a
benefit from it
that would really depend on the people
in those communities whether they
are willing to
be on those things for a start
and support them and whether they're
willing to pay for them
if an area decides they're going to have
a community board what they would do is
they would be assigned a special rating
and that rating would go towards a
community board it would be funding
their members their members make a small
wage because it is quite a big job to
take on a community board
and those rates that would be increased
would only be for those areas
they don't actually come out of other
people's rates who don't live within
that area that they consider part of
that community
so with the representation review people
have the option of choosing how many
counselors they want so we currently
have 12 in the past we have had 14 but
as of the review in 1993 they changed
that
and they went down from 14 to 12. they
decided that there were too many people
in the council and that it was
ineffectual
um what you can review now is you have
the option of going up or down again the
minimum we can have is 10 the maximum 14
that's based on the amount of people
that are in invercargill and
it's a plus or minus ten percent based
on that
um
so what happens in that is people need
to decide
some people find that 12 is ineffectual
they think that they don't get enough
done for that many people and they want
to save money by not paying the
councillors so they may decide that they
want to go down to 10.
other people may feel that they're not
getting enough people to vote from and
they'd like a bigger pool so they may
prefer for it to go up to 14 thinking
that it will be more effectual for them
to have a more diverse group or more
voices at the table the majority of
feedback we've gotten is to keep it the
same people seem to be quite happy about
it
i would say about 15 percent have been
for smaller and nobody has voted for
larger
so we'll be consulting with the public
all over invercargill and bluff we'll be
out in bluff at the four square
we will be attending the farmers market
there's a poultry
show in kennington in july which we will
be going to because we're figuring we'll
get lots of people from all over
we will also be at splash palace and
we'll be in windsor
just kind of trying to get a diverse
group and be around where people are and
get their opinions
there we have an era representative that
will also be going to the maori school
in sit and she'll be doing a
presentation there and she'll be tapping
into a lot of the local maori groups and
doing presentations amongst those
folks as well
the three main things that we really
want people to consider when they're
giving us their feedback forms is
communities of interest
fair representation and effective
representation to get more information
on that we have booked the booklet
available you can get it on the council
website or as i said you can also get it
from grocery stores
it's going to be available at the
library it's available at the pool
and at the council building
you